so this is what's being reported now
multiple uh outlets have carried the
story russian hackers
breached microsoft as part of their
campaign that infiltrated the u.s
nuclear weapons stockpile network the
los alamos lab and the energy department
officials reveal
so this is the latest update on what
they're saying is the biggest cyber
attack
in history i know that's not a lot to
say because cyber infrastructure is new
relatively in the past couple of decades
but this is an act of war i mean that's
that's basically what they're getting at
they broke into our nuclear weapons
stockpile
now here's the here's the important fact
in all of this how do we know it was
russia
exactly how do we know we even got
hacked exactly see
remember remember when they said the
gulf of tonkin incident was was
legitimate
then when people questioned it they said
you're a conspiracy theorist
and then they finally came out and
they're like we actually faked that
whole thing to enter the vietnam north
do you know what it was exactly they
blew up uh a ship of theirs the united
states oh they didn't blow it up at all
what happened my understanding is that
the initial report was i think the viet
cong fired on the uh
uh a us destroyer i believe i can pull
it up but the general idea was that one
of our vessels was attacked
in the gulf of tonkin and this was used
the rallying cry like oh they've
attacked us we must
enter the war everybody who said it
never happened was called a conspiracy
theorist and it was absurd to believe
the media was lying about it
and then i think it was like what 10
years ago whatever they were like oh
that whole thing yeah we faked it
we wanted to go to war so we just made
it up yeah but the the documents were
released and people found out that the
government absolutely lied to start a
pointless war
that wasn't about anything that they
were telling the people it was actually
about
and because of that tens of thousands of
americans died
and then hundreds of thousands of
vietnamese people died that led
to tremendous human suffering and just
the united states again
losing a war that it was in for for what
reason
check this out check this out this is
what the wikipedia so wikipedia is
pretty you know like
pretty hate me yeah check this out
here's what they wrote on sunday august
2nd 1964
the destroyer uss maddox while
performing signals intelligence patrol
as part of the desoto operations
was falsely claimed to have been
approached by three north vietnamese
navy torpedo boats
of the 135th torpedo squadron maddox
fired three warning shots
and it was claimed the north vietnamese
the north vietnamese boats attacked with
torpedoes and machine gun fire
madison expended over 283 inch 76
millimeter and five inch 130 millimeter
shells wow
in a sea battle according to the false
report
one us aircraft was damaged three north
vietnamese torpedo boats were damaged
and four north of vietnamese sailors
were killed with six more wounded there
were no us casualties
maddox was quote unscathed except for a
single bullet hole from a vietnamese
machine gun round
it was originally claimed by the nsa
that a second gulf of
tonkin incident occurred etc etc so
initially the reports were all that
you know we got attacked oh isn't this
hilarious wait the original american
report blamed north vietnam for both
incidents
but the pentagon papers the memoirs of
robert mcnamara
and nsa publications from o5 proved that
u.s government lied to justify a war
against vietnam
does that name sound familiar yeah
robert mcnamara
and we have to understand this history
of starting false flags in order to get
a country into war
is something that's common and it
happens a lot whether it's the reichstag
fire whether it's even the conversation
with the u.s joint chiefs of staffs in
the 60s talking about operation
northwoods
jfk said get out of here with that stuff
well yeah but operation northwoods
literally talked about
having fake hijackings there's there was
of course the baby in incubators in iraq
911 and there was many other instances
that that happened
all throughout world history that showed
how very powerful people conspired in
order to lie to their people to think
that they were under very powerful
so that's why we cite things on this
show so
instead of just moving on we stop i want
to make them pull it up we pull up
operation northwoods was a proposed
false flag operation against the cuban
government
that originated with the u.s department
of defense and the joint chiefs of staff
in the u.s in 1962. the proposals called
for the cia
or other u.s government operations to
stage or actually commit acts of terror
against american military and civilian
targets and blaming them on the cuban
government
this is on wikipedia and you don't got
to trust whatever it's there
it exists yeah so again what i was
trying to say here there's a lot of
instances
of this happening so to think that there
wouldn't be a digital
false flag is something that is very
naive especially when we look at the
revelations from edward snowden that
revealed
how intelligence agencies in the united
states have the capability to launch
false flag internet hacking attacks to
make it look
like another country is attacking us so
the united states intelligence agencies
have that capability
are they using it who actually hacked us
what actually happened here
good luck trying to find any evidence
well so he's trying to find any
information regarding to exactly what
happened
with this latest hack here's the
important thing i'll add i'll say to
this
did russia hack the us and one of the
most sophisticated and consequential
cyber attacks in history unknown unknown
yeah
possibly that's what they report us
they're saying it's going to be really
really hard to prove that when it comes
to something like the gulf of tonkin you
can show a ship with smoke coming out
you should look up the burning of it
right when it comes to digital hacks we
only have
official reports and statements you know
the problem i have with it is
i seem to remember a guy named i think
was clapper when he lied and claimed
there was no
rapper yeah no no he lied to congress
under oath yeah
general hayden and that said there was
no spying program at all when i
confronted him about the
you know uh family-friendly show the the
guys in the nsa who were caught
uh having masturbated yeah uh
you know super family i love that word
yes no not playing video games sorry ian
uh
i don't know this is generally lied to
me and told me no there's no spying
program doesn't exist of course they're
lying they're lying all the time
and edward snowden and julian assange
exposed a lot of that line
trump should pardon julian assange just
like just like ellsberg
exposed the gulf of tonkin in the
pentagon papers uh
you know these guys like snowden and
assange exposed
this stuff with uh what what got exposed
by
any false flags get exposed by these
guys by what snowden yes no no snowden
exposed that they were lying to the
american people about
warrantless and mass surveillance
stealing your information
and uh and they lie and they and and
that's what and that's what they do
that's what they've done and
it's because they're not beholden to
anybody they're they're they're an
entity unto themselves
the term false flag is so basic back in
the day thousands of years ago
a king would go or and take a flag of
his enemy and put it on a bunch of
troops and then go burn down one of his
own cities and be like they did it let's
go to war and it would be like okay
yep to get the people but but morale is
so when
it comes to going way back in history
you see the point of the false flag was
you could make people go to war but if
there's no morale and there's no energy
and
and zeal in that war people don't fight
very well
but if you show them look look they're
flying the flag of
gilder they kidnapped princess buttercup
indeed yes
then people will be like how dare you
they'll be really angry and they'll feel
it and they'll want to
fight they have yellow cake and they
have weapons of mass destruction
and you know the first gulf war was
really something extremely eye-opening
since
they literally hired a pr form to
talk about how babies and incubators
were ripped out by the iraqi military
and thrown to the ground and brutally
assassinated by the iraqis
and of course all of that came out to be
an absolute
lie yeah and the media really didn't go
hard that was a lie
yes and then people need to understand
that was the first justification to get
into
the first gulf war which was again
absolutely
pointless you brought up the burning of
the reichstagger and this is when hitler
well this is
what hitler used as an impetus to create
the appeasement
act and he said that when the reichstag
the capital or wasn't it the enabling
act the enabling act thank you it's
called the enabling act
um that when the reichstag was burned
down he blamed the communists and said
the communists burned down our
parliamentary capital
we need to take away everyone's civil
liberties and establish martial law that
was 1933 that was the beginning
of hitler's reign of terror more or less
he also launched a
false flag attack on the polish border
at a radio station saying that the poles
were attacking
he dropped some prisoners he blamed the
polish guy for burning the race tag uh
i don't know if the guy who burned the
rice tag was polish but there was a
separate false flag incident on the
polish german border
saying the polish invaded and they are
attacking our radio stations and
it was literally just a bunch of uh you
know criminals that they got put in
polish uniforms and then shot
that was wrong yeah so they they did
some tests on the reichstag and we're
like could
could what have hitler said happened
happen could one guy have burned down
this entire building as quickly as it
did
they blamed a communist for burning it
down of course
crazy so we have to be more attentive
than ever
with the possibility of a false flag
happening right now
and if it does we have to understand the
people who question it or ask
for evidence or any kind of information
regarding it will be
automatically wiped off from the
internet so i think this is a major
concern of mine
uh because this ability to be able to
communicate
rightful information i mean especially
during 9 11 a lot of people had very
serious questions about what happened
then
a lot of family members a lot of rescue
workers a lot of survivors that i
personally met and knew that were there
had very serious questions and a lot of
their voices a lot of their concerns was
able to go
out there to the general public because
of the internet
now we're living in such a tightly
controlled space where
i i really doubt that they would even
have a voice
in today's modern day and age i worked
at 9 11 i worked at the trade center i
worked at the american express building
across the street and i would work with
the firemen and they would come in and i
would ask like well
what where are the bodies and they say
well when we find a fireman we know
because
we don't find bodies but we find the the
jacket which is heat resistant we find
this white twizzlery substance inside of
it which is the bone everything else is
melted away
and they would fold it up and they would
take it and he said we don't find bodies
the bodies are in
under our in the liquid under our feet
running down into the east river
they're all melted and i didn't know why
is not officially a false flag they
don't know officially yeah they've done
they think they think that hitler was
using it as pretext
but the official history is that they
had a trial and they blamed this guy and
that was it
but they've done tests to see if the guy
could have burned down the entire
building as quickly as it happened and
they'd think it's impossible that it
would have taken multiple people
in multiple areas of the building to set
the fires and to have it all go up like
it did
yeah interesting so what happens if uh
you know antifa does something in
washington dc and then trump is like oh
and then he calls on the interaction act
like trump supporters want it could go
either way it could be
antifa it could be proud boys whatever
the excuse is we have to understand that
the political establishment
doesn't care who's going to be under the
bus so
it most likely could be pride boys but
it also could be anti-fog because i
could see a lot of antifa right now
they're not doing anything they're kind
of dormant especially with the lockdowns
especially with
the quasi-martial laws that are
happening which is especially perplexing
it should be perplexing for a lot of
people unless you're paying attention
exactly they're not but i think there's
going to be a resurgence
protest and i think donald trump's words
of saying that antifa is going
to have biden for breakfast i think he
said something similar to that uh
they're excited i i think they're
they're they're going to have a heyday
under his administration already there
is newsweek
publishing one of the craziest fake news
stories i've ever seen
where they claimed the proud boys were
wearing a shirt
that basically glorified the holocaust
and
that's just that's the lightest way i
can put it cause i can't tell you what
they're claiming the proud boys were
right but this is just
absolutely insane that's there's no way
that's true
and there was this image they posted of
a shirt
of an eagle holding the fascists the the
symbol of fascism and i'm like
that's that's insane is that on the back
of the us dollar no the eagle with its
talons holding the arrows in one foot
and then like they're not holding the
fascists the
kind of like a bundle of sticks is a
bunch of arrows well we have to
understand covering many protests and
demonstrations you know this too there's
always some crazy insane person
and if you want to cover a protest if
you want to make someone look bad you
always cover the crazy insane person
there
and you selectively choose but they
didn't have any photos of this guy
there's no photos there's no videos and
again it's very hard to believe anything
they say right now since they're
literally making stuff up out of thin
air just to
generate headlines just to generate
clicks just to generate revenue for
themselves
as they're part of a dying fleeting
industry that's becoming absolute
we got to be careful about blaming any
political party for any of this violence
because that's what hitler did he blame
the conflict well that's why i'm saying
well that's not a political party
i know but antifa or or uh proud boys
i'm saying with the history of false
flags it could go either way it could be
blamed on antifa it could be blamed on
proud boys it could be blamed on a
totally new group of people
that are meant to take the blame there's
there's a lot of possibilities here that
we have to understand are possible here
because the realm of of possibility is
very wide
and we have to understand at the end of
the day it's always their objective that
matters the most
that we have to be careful of thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you